what's up guys good to be here i am in
uh the apartment still of rachel
lindbergh
i probably shouldn't have said her full
name hopefully she doesn't mind
um
i mailed her her glasses today that's
one of the things that uh she needed
and that i was happy to do to be able to
stay at her place
uh so uh
i did that then she told me about this
ring light this gigantic ring light
and now i have a huge ass ring light
in this
[ __ ]
so that's cool
um
i will be at another house tomorrow
i'll be at um
uh curtis's house from the comedy store
he
is gonna
help joe rogan with his new club so i
don't know if i'm supposed to tell
people that but i mean he's pretty out
and about so i'm pretty sure he's public
um
but yeah i mean
[Music]
i'll be in another house i went from
having no house in a van to now having
two houses that i have access to so
north of austin and south of austin i
will be
homed and in a domicile for that
for this upcoming christmas a very nice
christmas present from
the beautiful residence of austin
um
so it's cool i have a house i have a bed
now all i need is a lady who's willing
to
put up with me
maybe i can make it like a fun time
hey what's up
uh you know
just create a hilarious time for
a lady which is important to do
um
yeah i love
having a home it's pretty fun
i love
being in austin i think this is a very
great city
i think austin is
gonna be great and it's already great
um i don't like the infrastructure i
don't like how it's set up to be so
spread out
and how you need a highway to get
everywhere and it's just gigantic
highways connecting to each other
it's just the wrong scale it's like
everything's too big we need everything
on a more human level
and everything will be more efficient
because then everything will be close to
each other and then you won't have to
drive
to go get a pack of smokes you could
just get one down at the corner store
but that's why i love the downtown area
in austin
because it's
all compact it's the one place where
everyone is at
and we've decided to put all this [ __ ]
at like if you're at 3am in the morning
in the night staying up all night at 3am
and you're looking for food good luck if
you're out in vlugerville or in the
suburbs
but if you're downtown near that
downtown area then you can find food
stuff you can find people partying you
can find people getting drunk
so it's just better uh to have
everything compact and everything close
together because it makes everything
more efficient
you get synergistic effects
uh having voodoo donuts next to
the vulcan gas company makes everyone
want to go
uh to
the vulcan gas company more and voodoo
donuts more it's just if you pack
everything close together it's really
cool
um
[Music]
why didn't i get casted on 20 somethings
on netflix probably because i don't look
like a god damn
fashion model
i'm more like just a normal looking
person
and i think that show is mostly
superficial
[ __ ] uh just people
pretending to learn how to sp pretending
to know how to talk
and not saying anything just having good
vibes just using conversation
to artificially inflate themselves and
make themselves feel better
[Music]
i think that my kissing bit on kill tony
was fun
i think it's great that
i was able to take part in that i have
this idea that sex should be something
that we do a lot more of
um
and i think that it's sad when we don't
do a lot of sex
i think it's sad when there's not enough
open mics
so i'm glad that i could do my part and
be like hey look if i could get a lot of
kisses then it's just like a matter of
perception and
we just need to start kissing each other
more and finding each other more
attractive and doing a better job of
making the world that we live in a
better place instead of just being
grumpy and
disgusted by everything
maybe just try to not be so paranoid and
smooch more people things are better
when everyone's smooching
have you begun kettlebelling i love
kettlebelling i am a follower of joe
rogan joe rogan i talked about
kettlebelling a lot i love the
kettlebell swings i've been uh doing
this thing at the gym
which i stopped going to for a bit
um
where i uh
look at the videos of like how to do a
bench press how to do a squat just
looking at it before i go up not even
with the sound on just to see like
someone doing it right monkey see monkey
do
am i right so then it's just like puts
me in the right mindset to just go do
that exercise and
a lot of exercising for me is trying not
to get injured my back my knees
my anus i don't want to prolapse my anus
by lifting too much
so
it's just a good thing to do to look at
people it's so handy that we have these
smartphones now and we can just pull up
whatever we want and if you're gonna
just be staring at nothing anyways you
might as well be staring at people doing
exercise at a high level and with the
proper form so that's pretty good
um
so i love exercising i need to exercise
more if anyone knows how to get a free
gym membership in austin i'd love to do
that i know
mr rogie is uh opening up a gym so i
hope i have access to that i hope he
doesn't mind if i
park my van in front of it and start
doing laundry in his parking lot no i'm
just kidding i wouldn't do that but i
would love to work out at this gym
because it's gonna be [ __ ] lit he's
gonna have everything there
and hopefully it's free
but hopefully i can shower there too and
use a sauna and isolation tank and it's
just i'm just like
hoping that i can use his [ __ ] but uh i
can also get a membership i have sixteen
thousand dollars in the bank account i
can usually
i can uh
buy a gym membership and if i'm really
dedicated to exercise then i'll probably
do that because that's probably a good
thing to do hey hans what time do you
usually stream
um i don't really have a set time i
usually stream like in the afternoon at
like four or five
because i like to wake up and write
today i didn't get to do that i was busy
playing starcraft and emailing a bunch
of clubs to see if i could go do a
god damn
co-headlining show with william
montgomery if anyone knows of any venues
in your city that you would love to see
william montgomery and ayat and maybe
even david lucas then let me know
because i want to book a bunch of [ __ ]
for february
december is
uh december uh january is already
built uh booked out
um
i usually stream whenever i can or i
stream late at night after i come back
from mike's so it really depends
have you come across that comedian from
20 somethings yes i know michael fractor
i don't know if his name is public but
that's his name he's a very nice guy
he's a very kind-hearted gentleman he's
got a very small head
which is something that in korean
society we really respect
um
share your personal financial
information with us i bank with a big
bank
and
i
have a checking account but not a
savings i should probably get a savings
account get like that one percent or
whatever
uh interest
um this is not my van this is an
apartment that rachel has let me stay in
and i'm very appreciative of that
uh i don't know when kill tony's going
back on the road it really depends on
what your city is like and if they
uh
you know do whatever
comedy of broadway in lexington kentucky
levity live in oxnard i would love to go
to these
places um
i think that it would be cool if you
guys could have them reach out to me
because i'm so tired of emailing people
i'll do it tomorrow it's like you can
only take so much
of the copy paste looking for their
email on the website they never put
their email on the website it's so
annoying
uh
why waste time on here live life to
write jokes about what do you think
other people are doing right now they're
not doing anything they're like [ __ ]
putzing about they're farting around
talking to idiots
uh i'm i'm practicing talking i'm
practicing
um going live having an audience and all
that
um so this is like an active thing like
this is like a cool thing to do like
this if if i was to watch something
uh
i'd probably watch
someone talk and say whatever the [ __ ]
they want to say i think that's
interesting that's an intellectual
exercise
and that's really
creative and interesting to watch people
do whatever they say
but yeah i love i love doing this this
is something that i'd rather do over you
know going out to a bar and drinking
with a bunch of drunk [ __ ] fat
buttholes
i was gonna say the f word but i forgot
that i this is not going out just to
texas it's going out to everyone
are you practicing performing in front
of the worst backgrounds
uh you hate this background it actually
makes noise
so that's cool
it's kind of an annoying texture it
looks like a grandma type thing but you
know it adds texture it adds like
whatever it adds a
differentness
i live in a sprinter van
um
what a douche thing to say
did i say building an audience i said
talking to an audience um
yeah i mean i like doing this i think
this is way better than a lot of things
that most people my age do and i don't
like hanging out with a lot of people
i think it's better to have a few deep
relationships than like
a lot of shallow relationships i think
we're not meant for shallow
relationships i think deep relationships
are the way to go
effort is bad
word uh
oh thanks for defending me rides and to
cruise bikes i'm sorry that i'm so
defensive i should be less offended by
things
are you doing any of the mics tonight
i'm doing my own mike kimchi mike and
then i'm doing a secret show tonight so
check it out i'm on the secret show
it's one of the best shows in austin
texas it's one of the best shows ever
it's just the energy is high the
expectations are high the audience is
great
red band runs it
uh so that's cool do you have a deep
relationship with david lucas i hung out
in the green room with him yesterday at
joe rogan show he was
very nice and kind and he killed it on
the show and he was just eating sushi
and listening to rogue and he had an
early flight tonight he's going to
atlanta so if you're in atlanta that's
where david lucas will be
uh what did you have to do to red band
to get the invite i had to suckle his
balls
and also just be a
regular on kill tony even though he
didn't book me last week usually he
books me and it's like whatever
i don't have to get booked every time
where do we find super show online uh
brian redband
or
uh vulcan
or big laugh
uh why is the secret show not live
streamed because it's people stand-up
acts and people don't like
uh
people don't like uh having their
stand-up act online even though i put
everything up online a lot of people
don't do that which is fine
um
i would do a roast battle with david
lucas
uh i would not
be
expecting to win but i think it'd be a
fun exercise and a fun thing to do and
plus like everyone expects him to be
funny so there's like an expectation
that they're going to have a good time
so then if i write a good joke then i
can sort of ride on his wave so
you know it's just a joke writing
a joke writing exercise
so i really like that what's your
favorite order in jacket the box i check
in the box the sourdough whatever i
don't really go to jack at the box jack
in the box
let's play some civ 5. i love the idea
of c5 i'll try to torrent it although
i'm not allowed to torrent on this
internet connection
um yeah i mean it's weird uh torrenting
is
so
awesome and i don't know why we aren't
allowed to do that
uh i remember the internet before was
taken over by corporations
and that was a better time and now the
internet is sanitized and boring and
the rough edges are
smoothed out
just like everything else um
uh
are you in your van nope
stop writing david's poll
i mean
if i could get more stage time i'd
definitely write david's poll
uh i would love to do sketch comedy i
don't know if i
my brain works that way but i would love
to learn how to use my brain like that
um i love starcraft 2 i lost earlier
today and the one game i played i'm o
for one and it was
a very long game and it's very drawn out
it was like a tiger that couldn't finish
off his prey
i
should have built more cannons to
prevent the side drops from happening
but
it was my first game in a while
and uh the guy offensive gg'd me he
gg'ed me when he was winning and uh
that's very uncalled for and really rude
and so it was like it was my first game
in a long time and i still barely
you still barely beat me [ __ ] loser
hack
so
i uh
i i left in a huff but you know it's fun
it's fun to engage in intellectual
combat with a fellow nerd online and
just learn about what he's into and what
how he attacks and what he does
so it's fun i could have done a lot
better but whatever
i see you've lost weight from that sauna
hangs oh you think i lost weight well
i've been working out i've noticed a
couple gains on my arms gg is good game
yes boomer uh just kidding
you're probably uh
young young man
uh
i need a i need a taurus or uh what is
that a what a torah is a vpn and then i
could [ __ ]
tour it games like zip five
where can i do some stand up as a first
timer at an open mic all you have to do
is sign up
when you first go i never realized this
because i've been doing it in the same
scene for a while but when you first go
everyone's like who's this is this an
audience member is this someone's friend
oh it's a first-timer oh hey what's up
and everyone's sort of looking at you
and judging you but that's just part of
the game and then you have to do comedy
in front of people who know that you're
a first timer so it's kind of hard but
if you could find like a real audience
i'd say go to a couple open mics and
find an audience that you think you
could do well in front of or an audience
that you picture to be what your idea of
comedy is and then write jokes for that
audience and then go on stage and
[ __ ] do that [ __ ]
toilet paper roll yeah i got a toilet
paper roll it's the handiest thing ever
how's dimethyltryptamine it's a spirit
molecule 6 squared is 36.
um
who you want to win for jake paul versus
wilder i think wilder's gonna win is is
jake paul just gonna fight everyone in a
sport that they don't do he's like gonna
challenge
wilder
uh
deontay wilder to an mma fight he's
gonna challenge [ __ ]
uh serena williams to a
game of foosball it's like why don't you
just do a sport and get good at it and
then challenge someone who actually does
that sport instead of challenging people
who don't do that sport
what is your only fans profile like it's
a lot of kissing girls that i met on
tinder who will let me film them having
sex
uh
so
yeah my girlfriend broke up with me
because the neighbors went on vacation
and i was rolling around in their garden
pretending to be a carrot
i mean if your girlfriend can't uh
indulge in uh
flight flights of whimsy and having fun
then i don't think that she's a good
person she's like you gotta be serious
all the time if you're kind of weird
then i'm i don't want to be with you
i think that's kind of boring um but
also you don't want to be in a
relationship with someone who's just
like
crazy and just like flopping around on
the ground and you're like ooh what is
going on here
um
i could tore it through my cell phone
it's just a lot of data that i don't
want to use
i only get 100 gigs before they start
throttling it
any memorization tips for on stage i
would say use a memory palace or do the
one button two shoe three tree four
store
five hive five wives
six sticks seven have an eight gate nine
rhine ten hen
so a ten hen is like a hen and then if
you have a joke about a dog just have a
dog chasing a hen and then that's ten
hand
nine rhine uh that's a marine orion
that's from starcraft uh so i would
imagine a marine [ __ ] in a bucket so
if that's i would joke about [ __ ] in
a bucket then i can do that
uh and then a memory palace is just like
a place that you are used to and you go
around looking at [ __ ] on there
um
uh
you're the man triple that
woodley too oh he's fighting woodley
someone said wilder
it's not my fault i mean i'm sure that
jake paul has a good uh whatever he won
the first time i just wish that they
would fight mma why why is woodley
boxing
uh like it's like being like oh i'm a
great boxer but what if i challenge
someone to an arm wrestling competition
it's like
just box
who cares about arm wrestling
it's like some specific
form of fighting that's not really
fighting
um
[Music]
it's uh it's not as easy to come up with
a new minute on kill tony
i have to do a little digging but i
think that i can do it and i'm excited
about next week i have some ideas
so it's just cool to do it and i just
hope i don't burn jokes and [ __ ] it up
before i have a chance to perfect them
so
gina hyena she
comes by every now and then she doesn't
come too often so i don't really hang
out with her
ufo disclosure
uh ufos are
a fanciful idea that i wish was true but
it seems like most of the
evidence is not that good and uh
i uh i'd rather spend time thinking
about the mongols
who actually existed i'm not high at all
thanks for asking i'm never high for
this i wish i was high
um
miss amy said i broke her heart i don't
know what the [ __ ] i did
um hans penny loaf says wtf what's up
hans penny love uh i don't know how i
broke miss amy's o's heart but um
oh she was supposed to give me some
shirt after the show or something and
then we never met up
but i mean it's like she's uh
she's uh was a little annoying at the
uh
kill tony
last time she goes around and greets all
the tables which is
uh it
like makes the audience feel weird so
say to miss amio maybe
don't make such a big scene and just
sort of like
try to
try to like don't just talk to people
for as long as you can
just sort of talk to them
and try to have good interactions good
short interactions and then let them go
on their way
[Music]
what's your favorite meal probably ribs
uh barbecue when you smoke weed can you
see any more uh yeah i just have to
look like that
that way i don't have to open my eyes
too much
what do you think of elon musk being
named times person of the year i think
elon musk is nice but in a instead of
elon musk there are 10 000
millennials who are working fast food
jobs or cubicle jobs that could have
invented awesome [ __ ] that we instead
make them work
and waste their life in pointless
occupations and i think that that is
wasted potential and i would like to see
everyone's potential unleashed
and i would want to see them do
something more with their lives than
flipping burgers
and
being a lackey to a rich corporate
businessman
and just wasting their time on reddit
instead of actually doing something with
their life i don't think we incentivize
people to actually do something with
their life i think we incentivize them
to gain
material wealth and hedonistic pleasures
go to concerts
have a ferrari
so we don't have the most inventive
people or people who are good at
contributing to the system that we live
in um
so i think that um
elon musk is nice he's a symptom of a
problem that we don't take care of our
people and instead we reward people who
are good at accruing capital and
resources
and elon musk is good at that and he's
good at
making
uh cool [ __ ] but i think that we're
missing out on a lot more cool [ __ ] and
that elon musk is only a small tip of
the iceberg for the genius that humans
have and i think that
it's sad that we're not using people to
the best of their ability instead we
just have elon musk who's good at like
tricking other rich people into thinking
he's smart and
he's good at
uh
design
um
i uh
i i don't think that uh
that's the best thing though like that's
the kind of stuff that we reward is uh
uh like apple steve jobs fancy design
and cool [ __ ] like that and i think that
we can have like a lot better of a
society and more inventors if we
actually let people do whatever the [ __ ]
they want
um
but instead we make them waste their
life doing whatever
um
instead of one elon musk we should have
10 000 inventors
um i'm sure elon musk is great at uh
burgers one of my favorite comedy
specials is bill burr
uh i think bill burr is awesome personal
drive plays a part i would like to see
personal drive taken out of the equation
and uh if you just have a cool invention
you don't have to like hustle and bustle
and prove that you're awesome but you
can just like be like hey what about
this idea and then we'll be like oh my
god look at this awesome idea that's
awesome my elon musk or my sat score was
21.50
um
we don't need janitors hopefully we can
get robots to do that but we need a lot
fewer janitors now than we did in the
past so we're just going closer and
closer to uh
unjanitorless society
but we still do need janitors at this
point and i respect the trade and craft
of janitorship
i think it's a beautiful thing if you do
it right who's my favorite kami my
favorite comedy's probably richard wolf
or hastanabe
uh the world needs a ditch stickers too
yeah but not as many as we did in the
past we're getting less ditch diggers
now and it's very very awesome
[Music]
is this your van no
uh
um
elon musk did a lot of cool [ __ ] i don't
know if elon musk is the best at
building software i think there's a guy
that's really good at building software
that is undiscovered because he doesn't
want to exploit other people and pay
them as little as possible and create
terrible work conditions
um but i think elon musk is doing the
best he can in the system that he has
and this is the kind of people that we
reward and do the best in our system or
people who
can create a good image of what they do
so i think that's that's cool that he
was able to do that
how do we let people do whatever they
want i would suggest giving them food
and shelter as a prerequisite and not
making people work
to survive because i think it's
uh unnecessary and when i'm forced to
work to survive when i know that you can
keep me alive for a lot less than what
i'm contributing
then it makes me resentful of the system
and i don't want to work for people who
are cheating me
and that's what i feel like is
is like a a reason why people don't
appreciate uh employment or work because
we can sense that we're getting [ __ ]
i'm not stoned
uh dude
so
i think elon musk is
adequately smart
i think there's a lot of burger flippers
that are smart and that are not being
used to their
the best of their ability
uh
yes you can ship me some rzstudios815
uh please send it to the vulcan uh gas
company jared nathan is so nice he's
very sweet um
i think that he's a very nice guy and
he's [ __ ] but he's also like he's
with it like he's not debilitatingly
[ __ ] and he's socially aware and
he's like really cool
uh toilets will always be clogged and
eating bugs will only make the problem
worse you have apartment now hans yeah
it's uh
my friend's apartment that she's letting
me squat in until the lease lends up uh
could i beat up elon musk i think he's a
big old big old man i think he's a
little older than me though so i would
have an advantage
in terms of age and um
i don't know i don't know if i could
beat up elon musk
uh that's a tough question
um
[Music]
can you give me food and shelter yeah i
can try uh depends on how cool you are
and if i want to hang out with you
but if you're not that if we can't get
along then uh i would like send you
money from afar
to go on stage and perform your first
set probably like six months i thought
about it when i was working this startup
job
oh so the question is how long did it
take
you to go on stage and perform your
first set uh six months sish
um i
i was thinking about i was listening to
joe rogan's podcast
i was 23 or something so this is eight
years ago nine years ago 22 or something
um
and i think that uh
it's funny because
i was gonna do it and then i got fired
and then i went back to home to seattle
and that's when i started i had to get
fired to start comedy because if i was
actually doing a job then i couldn't
dedicate the time i wanted and the way i
started comedy it was pretty cool
because i just started doing it and i
never stopped i haven't really taken a
significant
break since i started eight nine years
ago and i've been doing comedy non-stop
in a um
in a very very rapid uh multiple sets a
night type of way and in seattle i was
doing like four or five mics a night and
some of those were music open mics
there's a lot of music open mics in
seattle that gave me 15 minutes so right
when i started i was doing 15 minutes in
front of audiences boring their asses
off and doing really offensive terrible
jokes in front of them and getting
better so the people of seattle have
paid for the price of me improving so i
did that and i just haven't stopped like
a lot of people take breaks i haven't
taken a break i've just continuously
kept doing comedy so
i have that advantage i have that
momentum going and it's pretty cool
where does this food and shelter that
you want to give away come from
probably the amazing farm equipment that
we have that can replace 10 000 workers
with a tractor
we can pay for the food i think that we
do more than enough work to get food and
shelter
someone who works maybe six hours a week
can pay for their food and shelter
uh because we live in an efficient
society i mean it takes 20 hours of work
a week to survive as a hunter-gatherer
so it shouldn't take more work than that
when we live in a modern society with
specialization and efficiency we should
be able to just do the bare minimum for
uh food and shelter and then uh
and then uh
and then we can uh do whatever we want
with our free time and turns out most
people don't need to be distracted by
work to not become a terrorist they
actually want to contribute to the world
we want the world to be a better place
and
i think uh
i think that's a good way to go i think
people you need to trust people because
at the end of the day that's all we have
is people so if you don't trust people
well you're going to end up with people
doing what they want anyways you might
as well do it in a non-coercive way
instead of just
torturing them every day until you
eventually relent and they have a lot of
resentment build up
uh you don't have to work for the man
that is your choice i mean
it would be nice if we could just do
whatever we wanted
or it had been adequately paid
i mean
i guess everyone's definition of
adequately paid is different
[Music]
eleven dollars at santa's shop and now
make 40 as an
instrumentation technician
well maybe we could have health care and
maybe we could have the same labor
rights that they do in every other
modern country will mexico invade texas
they already tried that it didn't work
uh santa anna
we kicked his ass muraku
owen benjamin is his favorite comedian
uh i heard he went a little crazy i
think he took a edible from joey diaz
and he
um
[Music]
went uh he he got too high
did jared's mom let him stay jared's mom
did let him stay i can't reveal too much
but tune in to next week's kill tony if
you love jerry nathan
uh you have to work for snuff he's uh
on hgh and trt though
yeah i'm really really buff
to edit it
um
capitalism blows said from an iphone on
youtube i mean if only the internet
wasn't corporatized and monopolized i
think youtube is all right but i would
rather see
a lot of smaller companies and iphones
were created with a lot of government
inventions and patents
like the internet and smartphone screens
are made by governments
how many trammers does it take to change
a water pipe
uh hanzo you on trt obviously
if you couldn't tell by my massive chin
uh
i'm 32
so i'm not 25
do you stim cell on drip i wish
i'm not gonna ask joe rogan for anything
like that now
innocent auditor bragging about how many
subscribers he has um i mean have fun
with the uh
number of subscribers you have just
going around yelling at strangers i'm
just getting people to stare at my face
and telling jokes
but yeah i mean i'm glad that you're out
there doing your thing
uh
the world is not the same as it was in
the 50s
yes i can hear you on tony thanks for
being grateful that i got fired
uh if you don't want to work it's the
only system that incentivizes merit
actually capitalism is
a system where it helps people who own
capital who usually inherited it and
then don't do any work so capitalism
doesn't incentivize merit incentivizes
owning a lot of stuff already which is
what slave owners had
do you think being an asian has helped
you in comedy yeah i mean it's helped me
because i've
used it a lot to get ahead
um
i think that
uh
everyone has something that they use and
i use my asian-ness you can use your
midgetness or your whiteness whatever it
takes everyone has something so it's
like if people make fun of me for being
asian it's like whatever like we're all
doing something
um and my four vaccine mandates in uh
sweden or korea yes in america you guys
are too [ __ ] crazy for that
you guys will [ __ ] shoot people and
stuff but i think if you're managing a
herd of cattle and there's a pandemic
and there's a medicine for it
i would say give the cattle the medicine
we are the only sentient species in the
universe that we know of and we can't
just let a disease take us out we need
to do the best we can
to fight diseases so that we don't die
uh but if you want to take the risk so
you can keep going shopping by all means
go ahead i mean that's your choice
just uh don't uh get mad when everyone
bans
you americans from coming into their
country
and you deserve sustenance just for
existing i mean
i just think that if you don't give me
sustenance just for existing and you
have a bunch of it and you're making me
work more than i should for it then i'm
going to get a little resentful
and there's going to be some [ __ ] that
blows up
but yeah i mean i'm willing to work
i just don't want to be exploited
so it's just a difference in opinion
um
oh my god
i'm gonna try to read all these
uh
i don't have super chats allowed
i was wondering why i wasn't getting any
super chats
uh
anyone can already do that it takes me
five hours to hunt but then you feed
your family and your family didn't work
so then average is out and then plus
your neighbors can hunt for you and
maybe your wife can get some berries
[Music]
the genius idea for living in a van came
from not wanting to work and wanting to
make a lot of money
by not spending it and just being
economically frugal i think that if you
buy a mark a house on the free market
they try to
cheat you and try to [ __ ] you
so i wanted to make all my money
work for me instead of like giving it
away to other people
i don't know how to do super chats
uh i'm gonna turn it on um
we're all done via capitalism it's not a
coincidence
okay
uh karl marx or trotsky i don't know
trotsky i guess karl marx
it's not a coincidence planes trains
automobiles harnessing of electricity
was all done via capitalism well i think
it was just the system that was around
while we were
uh at that stage in technological
advancement i mean
would you blame feudalism for
the
great renaissance painters or
for the invention of calculus or was
that just the system that happened to be
in place
well
great people were alive
uh i think that with
technology it's an exponential curve so
capitalism is just an improvement on
feudalism but it's still uh
not all the way there to complete
freedom for people it's just like
replacing monarchs with capitalists and
rich people
but i mean it is great that capitalism
does incentivize people to make a lot of
money by inventing [ __ ] but it also
incentivizes companies that already have
a monopoly to stifle innovation
and make sure that no
no competitors can take them over by
buying them out
and
making sure that no one
creates a better product than them like
uh
andrew carnegie or hearst william hearst
with the uh
decorticator and the hemp like uh he
found that he had a lot of cotton and
then hearst found out that uh
hemp was gonna be awesome so he was like
marijuana is terrible we shouldn't make
marijuana and hemp illegal so there's a
lot of stuff like that that happens in
capitalism
uh where you try to maximize profit not
innovation so that's unfortunate
i realize you're roasting you what's
going on here
and you're hearing philosophy i mean
maybe i'm asian and stuff should
pregnant women microdose fentanyl to
give their children natural immunity if
you want your child to be like a party
rock star then i would say get them
started early
do some molly in there
throw in some
uh whatever uh
what is the food that is provided do you
really want to live in a world where you
what you eat is determined by some third
party here's your bag of rice and
potatoes don't feel like eating that
today well hopefully we have options
like if you go to a school cafeteria or
if you're in the army
they give you
whatever and hopefully it's delicious
i what is the food that is provided
i i don't think that just because food
is provided doesn't mean that we still
don't have a choice i mean we could just
have like the system that we have with
food stamps where you go to the grocery
store and you pick what you want
uh
yes the one percenter tricked me into
enjoying my mountain biking
i'm glad that you enjoy mountain biking
i hope you get to do that more instead
of working uh most of your waking life
for someone who doesn't care about you
hans looks like white rose from mr robot
you think you're entitled to other
people's things i'm entitled to whatever
i work for and the efficiency of the
society around me i think we should work
as a group
hans will be a millionaire in two years
but will he give his money away though
i will give away as much money as the
people need and as much money as i can
spare
if i am not happy or if the people
around me are not happy that i'm not
happy and i want to
make the world a better place but
honestly a millionaire one million
dollars it's communism is not about
giving money from
uh middle class people to poor people
it's about
getting money from workers
uh from rich people who all they do is
own stuff to people who actually work
for a living
and
um also
making workers get paid fairly for what
they contribute instead of paying them
the lowest amount possible
we'll show you tony a hell of a good
time in michigan
yeah
we in michigan now go wolverines
i don't know much about michigan
i'm gay comedy praise ella
seems less crazy than living in a van in
the city though
i'm sure he's great
i'm just talking [ __ ]
uh
for us to have bare minimum in life
sorry people vaulting following paper
and so more than other people's lives
you should get more stage time
than other comedians that live out your
socialism socialism isn't about
uh
comedians getting the same amount of
stage time it's about people not dying
but yeah you don't just share everything
you don't have to share everything in
communism you just have to make sure
that people have enough and get paid
fairly for what they do
will you be having a guest live yes i'd
love to but most people don't want to
come over i gotta book it if by bucket
people will come but that's just like
then i have to plan it out and change my
schedule
it's your biggest income stream right
now probably joe rogan is my biggest
income stream
i'm not 25 either
didn't think you were i thought you're a
very mature older gentleman mitch eru
what are your thoughts on the great
reset
is that the uh thing with the
uh whatever like the the pandemic
yeah i mean the great reset is great i
think we should reset it because because
things are [ __ ] up and [ __ ] is bad and
we should reset but i don't know what
the great reset refers to i'm not
familiar with that concept
um
chem engineering degree was worth it how
did the college years go for you i got a
mechanical engineering degree uh my
college years were spent playing
starcraft 2
uh in basketball i was pursuing passions
uh because i was not that enthralled
with scholastics
and academics i uh
i think school is good but i think that
it's uh
very factory-like they just churn it out
and hopefully you learn and it's not
very personalized and it's not very
relevant to what people actually do with
their jobs
i think school is good it taught me a
lot about physics and fluid mechanics
and all that fluid dynamics
but i think that um we just shove
everyone into schools and then
it's like a
badge of honor more than you're actually
trying to learn so i got the badge of
honor i haven't really used it i think
it's mostly useless and i don't like the
way that our system works in terms of
education
open your eyes
uh
hans when are you coming back to the
sentinelese islands that's a joe rogan
talks about that
uh you guys should watch him watch his
up amazing one of the best and i love
that i get to watch him twice a week
every week
we should give women and meat to people
who work
i mean i don't know if you have to give
women i think that if you're an
attractive man who can make enough money
and as a functional viable part of the
economy women will naturally be
attracted to you more than if you're
just a doordash delivery driver
and
if we just give people meaning and
purpose and a beautiful life then
they'll become more attractive and then
they'll [ __ ] more
um
these questions i'm reading them from
like back in the day i'm scrolling up
i just want to make sure i get everyone
capital equals property if you're
against capital you're against private
property so give up your stuff now
i mean uh people in soviet russia had a
lot of stuff uh stalin had a lot of
stuff
um
capital is uh things that you use to
gain more money
like factories and i think that just
owning a factory
is not enough to get as much money as
billionaires do especially when your
workers are getting paid minimum wage
um
most millionaires in america did not
inherit i mean bill gates came from a
rich family
elon musk came from a rich family
what is better than capitalism just
letting people slowly control more and
more of the economy that they live in
uh
yes you can come live with me for a week
um
[Music]
oh my god
i can't i can't do this i'm just going
to start reading from the bottom you
mean those stock brokers who sold jobs
virtually pull the levers of the stock
mine maximize the gain off artificial
increase seems like a crime 100 legal
yeah i mean i don't think stock uh
trading is that uh
ethical i think that it's just like
moving money around and sometimes you
[ __ ] over companies so that you make
more money
um
you're rich compared to 99 of the
population give all your money away
communism isn't about poor people giving
money to other poor people it's about
workers getting paid fairly from the
people who own capital
um
what do you think do you think austin is
the next big comedy scene yes this is
like a thousand percent yes because joe
rogan is such a powerful figure and
uh this is how
uh human capital works is that it's all
tied up in one singular individual at
times like mitzi shore was a very
powerful individual who created a
beautiful thing and that people
respected and trusted her and knew that
she would make decisions and so they
kept
coming to her
um
so i think it's great that joe rogan is
here because he's making awesome things
here
um is there the spinning ball of space
or flower stationary plane i think
there's no privileged frame of reference
so it might be spinning to us but to
other people it's not spinning and it's
like what it's all relative
theory of relativity so there's no
privileged frame of reference
the sun is not the center of the
universe our milky way is not the center
of the galaxy
it's just everything is uh relative
um
i have a 2014 freightliner uh
uh say that's all the rush starved under
socialism what about all the indians who
starved under capitalist britain's rule
or all the irish people who starved in a
man-made famine in ireland the potato
famine because the english
i guess hated whatever
[Music]
the state owns private property under
communism i mean you can do whatever you
want if you want to vote and like
not have that then you you should be
able to decide what you want but i don't
think that we are able to decide what we
want right now
i don't think we have democracy i think
we have a uh
oligarchy where rich people rule the
government
my van has like 240 000 i think i can
get to 300 or 400
maybe even a million
you need to be careful and stop
sleepwalking pretend like people are
naturally
uh
decent you're going to get screwed over
i mean it's like if you don't assume
people are naturally good then
what hope do we have as a species we
have to assume that we're good because
the species is all we have
so if you don't have any hope in our
species then like all this is for
nothing if we just constantly have to be
suspicious of each other and try to [ __ ]
each other over
we shouldn't be able to survive as a
species so the only way forward is to be
kind and create a better thing or do you
have the freedom to control our economic
lives why not start a business and pee
people as much as you see fit let them
do what they please and voted on company
policies
because we live in a marketplace that's
ruled by monopolies
we do not have economic freedom our
money is all controlled by
top one percent
millennials have five percent of the gdp
with that amount of capital we can't do
anything with it
um
and we can't take the risks that
where we should be able to take and to
create the world
as we know it as we want it
um
and i think that uh because we don't
have any power in our economy we're not
as sexy to ladies and we don't have as
much
sex i'm not high right at all right now
um i mean
in the us we don't really have economic
freedom all our economic all our
money is
with the one percent so they have all
the economic freedom i mean
go to baltimore st louis
tell them they have economic freedom
uh go to the ghettos compton in the
bronx
it's uh not a very great place
uh
freedom factory race
uh the irish famine was genocide yes
caused by the british
um
everything is relative is not relative
guess that statement is universal um i
don't know
ask ask einstein
uh nasa's figures cannot be actually
measured and they expect us to accept
what they say but would you be
comfortable not having the rights over
your van
i think that just because workers are
getting paid fairly doesn't mean that i
don't own a van anymore i think if
everyone if workers get paid for late
there's more vans that more people own
um
i think a lot of this is like just what
americans think
giving workers rights will lead to so
then we never give workers rights
because we're like we can't do that
that's what other people do and they
suck
the u.s has pulled more people out of
poverty than any other system it's not
even close actually i don't think that's
true if you look at china or
russia
they pulled a lot of people out of
poverty through school but wants to be
paid more i don't want to be paid more i
get paid enough i want you guys to be
paid more i think that you if you work
that you need a lot of money and you
should be getting it it takes a lot to
keep a human alive and we shouldn't just
be squandering
human capital by paying them as little
as possible
and i also think that if you have a
zoo or a tiger is being kept better than
a human that something is wrong and that
we should be treating people better to
get the best out of them don't you need
to share your van with the homeless
comrades
communism is not about poor people
giving away
all their stuff to other poor people
it's about
people who own
capital
uh
paying their workers
fairly
uh i wish this was a green screen this
is actually a
just a white screen
i would love to share my living space
especially with a sexy lady
so
anyone want to start a commune with me
uh please come over you must have
a beautiful vagina or
a clean [ __ ] that maybe i could
experiment with
just kidding i'm not gay
um
thoughts on bill hicks oh i love bill
hicks one of my favorites he was funny
and he was poignant and i also agreed
with him a lot
so that's cool yeah we're rich people
but the solution is not to give the
government more power and influence over
our lives well maybe the solution is to
make the government actually uh run by
the people because
the government is only threat to
uh corporations that's the only way we
can stand up to them is the power of the
government
so i don't think that uh the government
is inherently evil i think it's just
used inefficiently now if you're in
tony's shoes and you're able to pick the
new next wrangler from austin who would
it be and why
i don't know
um casey rocket i think is funny
[Music]
there's a lot of funny people here i
just i'd have to look through a list
i'd rather
maybe i should talk about the scene more
um the scene's great here
um
there's so many funny people i mean it's
not as good as new york or la obviously
but i think it's
uh third place and we're getting better
and it's gonna get even better when we
have the [ __ ] headliners here killing
it so i think that it's gonna be a
bright future for austin and i'd rather
be here than any other city that's why
i'm here because new york and la is too
[ __ ] up with entrenched powers the
people that already own that [ __ ] are
[ __ ] it up and they just want you to
kiss their ass and they're really good
at kissing ass so all they respect is
kissing us
i think those people are weak
i think that their only skill is to be
able to sell out and that they get
really good at selling out and then they
wonder why other people aren't selling
out
um so yeah
i think austin's better austin has a
better soul
uh people here are fresh and they're
actually being rewarded for the stuff
they do instead of just being like an
old guard and owning a lot of shows uh
straight-up commies using technology
i mean
technology was come made by the
community so i guess if you're using
technology from the community
then you're a communist but i don't
think uh
capitalism has a stranglehold on
technology i think we can actually get
better technology if we democratize the
internet and get rid of corporations and
monopolies
and people who own the capital of the
internet and then we could actually
share information with each other freely
instead of having to do it
through these
big corporations
um
uh did not work out very well from
marist ellen the sharing your food stuff
i mean mel
was uh trying uh he had the
russians for an ally and then the rest
of the world was against them
the whole world was trying to [ __ ] with
russia and china because they didn't
want to see
uh
people having more power it's like when
the french revolution happened
and all the all the countries in europe
were like oh no you killed your king oh
no we can't have that we're gonna invade
you
so like whenever people try to get more
power all the other countries are like
this is bad this is going to make it
look bad
i mean crony capitalism is bad but i
think capitalism where a few people have
all the money leads to crony capitalism
fascism is when corporations enforce
government mandates
um
can we all just love each other that's a
good idea
i'm gonna see how to
enable super chats and maybe i can
capitalize on my communism
um
i have memberships
supers i think they're called
super things
oh i guess
i had it turned off
because they turned off my [ __ ]
which is annoying
um
so i think i turned it on let me know if
super chats is available
yeah um
we are a tyranny not a capitalist
society they get us where most of the
people are on government subsidies it
doesn't seem to be working there can you
imagine if the ghettos had no government
subsidies it'd be even worse than it is
now
uh fairly is a measurable yak does it
fairly is a measurable term i just think
that it should be something that we
should strive for instead of just giving
up
and uh being like we're going to make an
unfair system
i think we should try to be fair
um next time you get down haunts
remember it could be worse and you can
be named gaylord
um i love parker's
uh
was lothario the original super spreader
i hope i didn't spread any coronavirus
but honestly like if you were not trying
to get coronavirus
i don't think that we would have done
the things that we did i think there's a
market for van life
um
korean mandatory military service for
two years any thoughts uh i think that
it is unnecessary and it takes out a lot
of
uh useful life
from young men's lives in korea um
so i don't think that's very cool uh
all zoos should be banned
i made a lot of money
i don't think china has a better system
than the us i think that
china
is a little more thoughtful which is
nice but i think
the us is the future of like free speech
individual respect freedom
and i think china is like all [ __ ] up
and stupid and they're still living in
their old world
um
yeah i mean rich people have more to
share
the van i'm not in the van anymore
i uh keep trying to read every single
thing and i don't think it's gonna
happen
um
china has social credit score
you know what how much would you donate
crypto i'm poor
sure
um
i don't have 12 minutes i have more than
that
i'm gonna go turn on the ac
here's some royalty free music
hopefully you enjoy
this clown chaser
i think you can hear it
[Music]
[Music]
okay the ac is
um
yeah i mean
i think it's uh
good to be here 6 39
i probably have to leave at like 7 30
because i need to go to the secret show
by 8 so i have a couple more minutes of
this
um
are you an island boy i'm an island boy
you're ready for your host hans come
was that
that was actually cloud chaser spence
royalty free music no copyright music
instrumental music free download you
need to go visit tom green and play some
pond hockey i would love to i'm i love
ice skating i'm all right at ice skating
but i'm not good at
uh
i'm not good at uh
i'm not good at hockey hockey's hard
those guys are really good at skating
i'm not that good they can stop i can't
stop i gotta run into a wall
and i need to be able to escape
backwards
i thought norm mcdonald was an amazing
comedian
um
let me know if super chats are working
or not uh
it's pretty hot on tw in austin right
now
uh han sexy right here will make more
people better off doesn't mention that i
didn't get to read it
um
good night mcdonald's is delicious do
you think you'd get to practice comedy
in a marxist system you'd be sent to the
assembly line for the collective i mean
russia had pretty good art they had good
ballet they had good propaganda posters
i'm not stoned
uh they had a good hockey team speaking
of hockey
um
are there any other arts you like i
drama music etc yeah i love all arts
uh
should i
restart
stream
whatever
i have the internet uh
as an asian american i would say i'm an
industrious person and i think it had a
lot to do with my family and my
upbringing and like my general hatred of
myself and my
uh
acknowledging that i'm a pathetic little
useless piece of [ __ ] and that if i want
to do anything useful it'll take hard
work instead of just being comfortable
and lazy
um i think that's
uh
crazy
yeah russia turned out great ever heard
of the holodemour
yeah i mean the whole world was allied
against russia france spain
great britain america every major power
was trying to [ __ ] with russia and the
whole of demora was bad and it was run
by stalin who was
not a community member he was not the
whole community he was just one person
in it
uh and it was a time after world war ii
or before i don't know when to happen
maybe in the 30s
okay after the great war
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up
they were trying to create this [ __ ]
uh and it went awry and famines do
happen and in fact the great bengal
famines were way more costly in terms of
lives and that was caused by capitalist
great britain so if you're comparing
famines to famines i would say that
capitalism is way worse than
communism
because of the great bengal famines
where
millions of indians died
uh and also
if you
care about white people dying then you
should check out the potato famine
um
yeah so apparently if you rejoin the
stream then uh the [ __ ] thing works
ukrainian is farming grain for russia
and not allowed to eat it yeah they were
they had their grain stolen from them
their ukrainians would
have all this grain and then stalin
would be like hmm i think that you're
hiding grain for me give me more grain
more green more green i need more green
and he was like a paranoid schizophrenic
leader and all that
uh if capitalism is so bad why does
everyone want to move here probably
because we [ __ ] up everywhere else in
the world like south america we
definitely [ __ ] up because we were
jealous that they were giving their
people their land back and wouldn't let
us farm bananas there
um
i um
[Music]
also southeast asia has been pretty
[ __ ] up by america africa has been
[ __ ] up by europe
middle east has been [ __ ] up by europe
and
america uh china china's doing good even
though it's kind of [ __ ] up too
i'm not a big fan of china i think that
we need the future and the future is a
hybrid mix of all the races and
countries coming together that's why i'm
glad to be asian-american i can bring
them in my asian side mix that with the
koreans at the american side and you get
uh
you know the most prolific kisser in
kill tony history
so you know you need a combination of
asian small cockness and american
aggression to get get someone to go
around kissing as many people as i do
i wish alex jones is here uh
i have another microphone i would love
for someone to join me it's just not
happening
um
are you high lol i'm not high i can't
believe i answer this question people
get annoyed that i answer are you high
but i wish i was high
this is just how i normally talk and i
think it's weird that when people will
be like oh super chat works i told you
how many comics would you estimate are
in austin i'd estimate 500
maybe a thousand i have no idea
uh what was i talking about um
were you ever worried about getting
herpes no not worried about that i don't
think people as dirty as people make it
out to be
um
oh yeah getting high people want to know
if you're high
uh because they want to be like do i
have to can i ignore you because i like
ignoring people and not taking what they
have seriously that's a lot of work for
me to have empathy for other people so
if i can know that you're on drugs then
i don't have to take you seriously but
even if someone is on drugs you should
still listen to them and take care of
them and be nice to them in fact some
would say you should be even nicer to
them and more empathetic if they are on
drugs
so i would say that
it really doesn't matter if someone's on
drugs usually when people are asked that
they're like should i should i be nice
to you
are you on drugs because i really don't
want to give you human decency i'm kind
of spent on that so if giving human
decency is hard for you then uh i would
say work on your stamina but like uh i
know that most people aren't asking in
that way i'm just talking about like in
terms of like people who ask that in
real life like are you high right now oh
oh my god you're high you're not even a
real person anymore i have only empathy
and only able to see the humanity in
people that are exactly like me and in
my same mental state
free markets are great it did create a
great country called america but i think
it was just an improvement on feudalism
and if you look at it as a spectrum
feudalism capitalism then we just need
to keep going we can't just stop here
like this isn't a good stopping point we
need to give people more rights instead
of just giving rights to people who have
inherited power like monarchs and
capitalists i think that we should
create a real meritocracy instead of
rewarding people for having already been
rich
wrong with being high
don't like 90 of people have the herps
anyways exactly
did he already explain what's on his
shirt looks like a comic book this is
lady owl
uh whatever
it's uh from uh this band
lady owl
uh and it's
a band and they sent me the merch
through the mail and then i wore it
and so check them out well i'm on trees
on mars
uh
do you think some places just suck
because of the people there or is it
always the fault of an outside force
i think that most places are going to
try to figure their [ __ ] out and create
a nice place to live
some places just have a bad culture
because there's a volcano and
it blows up all the time
but
i think the history of the world is uh
pretty
interesting and if you look at it you
can see like where
everything came from and stuff
um
i can't believe that hans is stoned out
of his mind right now insane it's funny
because everyone thinks i'm stoned all
the time and it's actually kind of
offensive
in terms of living standards actually i
don't think we have a meritocracy i mean
if you look at social mobility if you're
born in the lower class how
what chance do you have of getting into
higher class it's not
it's not a that meritocratic
um
we're at 27th and social mobility
we did
before coven
did texas do 9 11 i mean texas loved 911
they were doing whatever all right you
uh
race and iq perhaps some areas are bad
because of low demographic low iq
demographics and not capitalism
i don't think that uh
there is a significant correlation
between race and iq i think people are
intelligent in different ways asians are
smart in a very boring nerdy stupid
bookish way
and africans are smart in a more
uh
intuitive and
uh awesome way and uh
yeah i mean i don't mean to compare
asian and african intelligence but i
think that they're more than capable of
having a functioning country the only
problem is they've been colonized
uh by outside forces and uh
tortured and
raped
and i think if none of that would have
happened i think they could create a
very
stable country and i think that we
should let them do it
but unfortunately we killed lumumba
in the congo
the cia killed the mumba
after
a horrible occupation by the belgians
so i mean you try going through the king
leopold's colonization of your country
and then having the cia kill your
patrick lumumba and see how good of a
country you make
uh i think that it's crazy because like
yeah i mean if you just let countries
develop like they would do way better
than how they're doing now and it's
amazing that um
it's amazing that they've been able to
do as well as they have done so far i
think the human spirit is amazing and
then they've been able to come back
through all that [ __ ]
uh if it's not accurate that most rich
people got their money through
inheritance the vast majority of
millionaires are self-made i think that
if you look at america a large part of
the wealth comes from
inheritance and being in a rich family
and the advantages that gives you
very few people in the bottom of the
rung make it to the top of the rung and
that's on purpose
am i related to the rooftop koreans
maybe in spirit but not genetically my
parents came here in 1989 and lived in
new jersey when the l.a riots was
happening
[Music]
yeah there's no difference between
groups we're all equally intelligent
it's only a cons incidence that plane
streams and automobiles came from
certain groups
that is racist uh
i mean it's great that europeans were
able to invent some amazing things they
had some advantages in terms of
geography and
they had a good governmental structure
that allowed intellectual property but i
think that
[Music]
that is not a sign of uh collective
intelligence i think that is that you
could still meet a lot of stupid white
people
um
and i don't think that we should be held
responsible for the inventions of our
forefathers
uh
so yeah i mean i don't know
uh
what's with you talking about race all
the time i'm just interested in it what
are you interested in i mean we could
talk about like buttholes and like
farting and
poopy
hair and
dogs
um i don't think that white people are
that
much better than other people i mean
have you met other people they're pretty
cool too
uh i don't see white people being
superior as a race
did you know the government has killed
like 100 billionaires in china i know
it's kind of crazy
but hey that's what you got to do you
got to call the field sometimes
what is interesting about race it's all
around us it's our genetics it's our
history it's our dna
it's our animal instincts that we're
fighting all the time
i'm not sleeping i'm doing fine some
people don't just
have to have a lot of energy to
think that they're entertaining i think
that uh
you know what a lot of people want is
just like bells and whistles and i don't
think that's
really the best way to go
has you discussing your wiping methods
open up any cottonelle sponsorships
i wish
my wiping method is actually only good
for toilet paper
a lot of
you know white wet white people aren't
really into that
uh
unsubscribed
i
know i had a very civilized hearing in
the game answer
thoughts on the jab i think it's
relatively safe
race isn't anything important we were
made in a lab at one point
oh is that some conspiracy theory
um
i'm in an apartment my friend let me
live here
how long do you have to practice martial
arts until you fly like the movie
uh crashing tiger uh
what is the best way to coordinate our
collective peasant energy to defeat
reach rich people i would say that the
best way to coordinate our collective
peasant energy would be to
vote
and use the power of the government to
destroy monopolies and corporate
malfeasance hounds your head is bigger
than my future thank you i have a very
big head it contains a very big five
brain brain
and it's just like a [ __ ] awesome
brain
um
is bobby lee your hero he is one of my
heroes he embraces uh
he embraces humor he embraces uh
hilarity
uh and he doesn't try to impress the
old-school koreans he's just funny the
way he is
uh i usually kick one leg up on the wall
and use a mirror in the floor to make
sure it's a wrap
uh crush me dug a hidden pupil very
funny because my eyes are small
uh
us autistic people have large heads look
it up i got diagnosed off childhood
photos
what's your favorite word at the moment
probably
the f word do i have vemmo yeah my venmo
is in my group
uh my my description
um
yeah we shouldn't defeat rich people we
should just appease them and make sure
that they get whatever they want so they
can keep letting us have basic human
rights
i do typically write sober nowadays i
don't always like to i would love to be
on tiger belly
uh
i guess everyone touches her face a lot
indo i haven't been smoking and i've
been smoking whatever free weed has
passed to me usually
uh
if you have a smaller head it means
impulse takes less time to travel
between neurons
yeah
having a small head is better
i just have more brain matter did you
really kiss william's sister that's just
a joke we call them the montgomery
sisters because they're red-headed
you'll see it in the episode how how are
you right now i'm going to highlight
pink guy
very then literally curl down and
destroy their own corruption well with
interactions stop shopping on amazon
castle and buy food in local farm
i mean
buying local is good uh it's hard to
avoid monopolies because of their
monopolistic tendencies
um
the government is corrupt so we should
just leave it corrupt and not try to fix
it or should we try to fix it i would
say let's fix it let's make it better
um
helen's game comedy uh you watch any
youtubers if so who i like a lot of
youtubers i like uh
majority report with sam cedar i love uh
hassanabe i love h3
uh a lot of people that
hate uh other people that i like
um
i love starcraft 2 on youtube i love
others
uh should banks allow poor people to use
their spare kidney as collateral instead
of requiring a down payment when
purchasing a home that sounds dystopic
um i would rather not have people have
to sacrifice their kidney just to buy a
home i think we could create a better
system than that i think that there's
plenty of resources in the world
to
make sure that we don't have to
sacrifice our body
for whatever
lie my way onto infowars and get 10
times my following with people that are
going to hate me more than you guys
already hate me
i'd rather build a build an audience
slowly and quietly and
doing whatever i'm doing hopefully you
guys enjoy this we can make government
better by bettering ourselves with our
church so we make turrets i very much
agree with you and we are turds on
purpose they don't fund our education
and they turn us into
uh not as
good people as we could be so that uh
democracy doesn't work
uh oh wow you're a real seattle bubbly
left
huh
yeah i'm pretty left so as the rest of
the world
with autism becoming more common do you
think it's just another step in human
evolution
[Music]
i i guess so i i don't really think
about it i think autism is like
people call me autistic when i don't
like to be touched i do like to be
touched i just don't like to be touched
in the way that idiots touch me like you
can't just like go around touching
everyone and being like oh you don't
like
uh
you don't like to be touched it's like
maybe you should have more care and
discipline in how you touch people like
if i was bad at like you know
um
if i was bad at whatever
um
if i was bad at
uh
if i was bad at making food and i'm
giving food to everyone and they're like
oh i don't like this food i want to be
like oh you hate food huh that's weird
like usually people like food but you
hate food it's not food that i hate it's
you your food the way that you made it
like people don't uh
want to admit that like they don't know
how to touch people they they just want
to blame you for not being able to be
touched but maybe you should get better
at touching people in a way that they
like instead of
going around
surprising people with your touch and
acting like you get to touch every
anyone
everyone any any way you like and then
they have to respond to it and if they
don't then it's their fault
uh have you listened to the peter
mccullough episode of jerry and her
government corruption academic
incompetence is a gigantic failure on
how coveted was mismanaged in the u.s
i haven't heard it i know about it i
i don't necessarily agree with that i
think that we knew what to do besides
the whole mask thing in the beginning
where faucet was like don't warm us
uh i think that there's very obvious
steps that we can take and all that
uh
you all need to drop more super chats
also follow osmosis reacts on youtube
he's plugging his own [ __ ] hey that's an
ad i don't mind
uh thanks for the ad
um
build that wall mad aliens jump the
border
uh i don't think that's really the
problem i mean if you want to
build a border wall
um
i just uh
i don't know i just don't think that's
the problem i think that we need to give
workers rights even if we close the
border we're still going to
be having an unequal wealth distribution
um
would you rather go on jerry alone or
threadband or something um i think
if it's gonna happen it might be with
all three regulars i think that would be
[ __ ] awesome
uh that would be a fun hang i love
william's energy i love david's coolness
but i mean
when i picture it i always pictured it
uh
alone so that would be
that'd be cool i would want to do both
like shane gillis was on there
with ahri and mark normand mark norman
was on there alone
you know it's like i want to do both
because it's just such a fun hang and i
hope that joe rogan enjoys
having to kill tony's regulars on uh
on his shows because he keeps booking us
so i guess he likes it
marxism is not about unlocking your
doors marxism is about
paying workers fairly and workers of the
world uniting to fight against the power
of capital and that's why america and
great britain really hated it because
they thought it was gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up
for them
and their an equal wealth distribution
have you admitted to yourself that you
are a communist already i mean what is
communism giving workers rights should
we never give workers rights i think
that uh workers should have rights and
if you work i want you to have a lot of
money because then you'll be more
pleasant to be around and you won't cut
me off in traffic and yell at me and
[ __ ]
uh do you still practice guitar no i
wish i could i jammed my finger playing
basketball both my index fingers
uh peace from the middle east hey why
don't you keep that piece in the middle
east y'all need it
kami gobbly goop
uh yeah i mean communism if you label
everything that can improve your country
as communism you're never going to
improve unless you embrace communism
so you're just setting yourself up to
eventually need communism but if you
just say this isn't communism this is
just
uh
the american way of taking care of each
other if you just relabel it then you
can figure it out
um
yeah i mean what happened in china that
would make china [ __ ] up maybe the
boxer rebellion and the forced opening
up of trade with opium letting great
britain sell opium inside of their
country [ __ ] up their population
um
and uh
devastation by the japanese
uh are you gonna play the new cap city i
would love to
i uh
if they will have me
um
can you see after you've had a black or
swollen eye
i mean
i think my eyes are more resilient
because there's less of them so it's
less whatever
basketball is communist um okay i guess
there's a community involved in the
scoring of the basket but i don't know i
think the label communism has lost all
meaning and that uh
i don't know
i don't know what we really think about
it i imagine hans you get high
and go on these rants rather than the
camera is on or not lol who else is in
the chat is from atx when we going
shrooms lol
i guess if you do a super chat you don't
really have to proofread it
um
uh
yeah i mean i love getting high i love
talking so i hope i can combine the two
a great example of someone who is
likable despite differing political
opinions i hope that you're talking
about me and not craig candor how do
people get rich in marx's system
um the same way that
they do it in finland let's just have
finland can you play video games like
escape from tarkov what
me i haven't played that before
i love uh
i love uh games open your eyes
uh do you think jeremy lynch come out
and support taiwan or keep bringing in
in that dollar
i mean do you really does taiwan really
need jeremy lin even if jeremy lin comes
out in support of taiwan what's going to
change for taiwan why why are you trying
to [ __ ] up jeremy lin [ __ ] taiwan
just keep doing you you're doing fine
uh you're gonna do great just
figure it out
we could have finland but multicultural
we could have a multicultural finland
let's try it i think it's possible
um
i have not read gulag archipelago
is that like animal
farm who about in china
how long do you spend writing to come up
with your new one minute every week well
i write a lot and then i throw away a
lot i write try to write 2 000 words
every day i think i heard it on joe
rogan's podcast but i try to write 2000
words every day which is like an hour
and i think it's good because even if i
don't come up with something i think
about what i'm gonna say and i think
about my jokes
uh so it's just good for me to do that
do you care for league of legends i
haven't really played it i don't really
care for it just marks abbreviation of
kev observations of capitalism yeah
marxism is just marx's observation of
capitalism and how it eventually leads
to one person having everything what's
your opinion on ancient cultures being
understood and the solar system and
universal truth without modern science
and the claim they
make of the knowledge being found within
self i think you can get so far with
that kind of knowledge you can look at
the stars and figure out
what's going to rise at what time but i
think that's very limited and what's
better than
what's better than
what's better than looking at stars and
measuring your belly button is
you know like electricity
and
wi-fi technology and touch screens
i have stream for my van i'm currently
in not a van right now
i love the ufc i'm a huge fan of combat
sports i think uh with our vicious and
animalistic culture ufc is a huge
release and it actually shows us
the end uh
and uh of our uh
it shows us the
end culmination of our fantasies about
hitting each other and pummeling each
other and how actually it's very
difficult and it's a very beautiful art
form but i think like living in this
world it's crazy because we are always
at each other there's throats and
there's always the threat of violence
and it's just cool that uh we get to
actually see it happen
uh because we're living in a very
coercive society that i don't appreciate
like that's the thing when i go to asia
it does it's there's just a weight
lifted off my shoulder i'm not i don't
have to look over my shoulder i don't
have to [ __ ] walk fast or
pretend i have confidence and make
people afraid of me i can just exist
and i think that's something that's
missing in america is like it doesn't
feel like a society it doesn't feel like
a human
culture it feels like everyone's trying
to kill each other and if you make a
wrong move you could you could be done
for and i
don't think that's healthy
leftists tend to not think for
themselves people parent nonsense and
make it about how moral they are
i mean leftists are more collectively
oriented uh in terms of the world right
people people on the right are more
collectively oriented in terms of their
racial group or their small
economic minority
in your opinion but i found that is able
to be tapped in through your mind i find
that my body and soul is technology
already
yeah yeah but you can't power my iphone
through your brain electricity yet i'm
sure we're gonna be able to do that i'm
gonna be able to like touch things and
impart electricity through it but uh
yeah i mean i think real science is more
impressive than ancient science although
ancient science is impressive it's cool
that
it's cool that
they could do that i just think that
there's more to science than just
staring at the stars but i think that is
really cool too because it's like a
natural
pathway from our natural thoughts into
science so i think that's cool
what do i think happens after death i
think we die and our body decays and
falls becomes a part of the earth and
the ideas that we are left behind that
uh that the way that we made people feel
and the ideas that we have and the
books that we wrote and the movies that
we made
that that lives on that is our afterlife
is
what we did in the work that we did and
the impact that we made on others
reverb reverberating through eternity
until eventually
uh it goes away but even if the idea
die that you created
uh the ideas that respond to those ideas
don't die the people responding to the
people that you impacted don't die and
that's the uh afterlife is just us
living on through our species or
whatever consciousness happens to come
across
our life's work
so i think uh
we need to make our existence beautiful
and we need to shine as bright as we can
and hopefully people will gravitate
towards it and be able to use it in the
future and make themselves better and
that is afterlife we live on through
each other
and i
don't want to die now but if i do i'm
fine with it because i have faith in my
species and i know that they will
they will carry on without me
i'm happy to have been a part of it and
i'm excited to see where it goes
so i uh replaced my thoughts of heaven
and an afterlife with my hope and
aspirations for the species that i
happen to be a part of and not even the
species but sentient life
and the power of
logic and
whatever is going on inside my head so
hopefully i can live on through that
um
boy are you in for a pleasant surprise
hey if there's heaven i'll enjoy it
um and there's a new opening act on kill
tony i mean i'm opening it up for the
next two weeks at least
and uh jared nathan is gonna be a part
of it jared nathan is beautiful
beautiful soul so i can't wait for you
guys to see that [ __ ]
um
i uh
i
yeah i mean a lot of people find my uh
afterlife thoughts depressing but i find
it very hopeful and very
inspiring so
you know don't [ __ ] on my shitty version
of the afterlife you know it's like
how come i can't make fun of your stupid
little childish ideas of clouds and a
bearded man but you get to make fun of
my beautiful ideas of something that's
actually going to happen it's like the
species is going to exist beyond any of
us and continue even though it's made
out of us
there is no having in communism
communism is where you don't have
nothing
nothing
and that's just it
like i mean
isn't it weird that uh
all these people have such strong ideas
on communism and yet
all that they know about is from the
american side of things
like uh there's not a lot of knowledge
going around about communism and yet we
all have these things that we parrot
i mean communism
means no possessions i guess uh
communism is uh
where people who are super rich don't
have all that money and that we can all
vote on
how much we want to get paid so then
super rich people are not going to have
as much but
i think that you're confusing exorbitant
exuberant exorbitant wealth with no
private possessions and i think there's
a middle ground between people being
super rich and nobody owning anything
that we can hit that is very obviously
attainable
that we should be striving for because
right now we're too far on one end of
the spectrum we're not suffering right
now because
too many people have too much stuff and
there aren't enough rich people we're
suffering right now because we have too
much rich people and all our wealth is
trapped up top and we can't change the
world
to see to to to the way that we see fit
but communism is the answer look at
utopian china and north korea or is
capitalism the answer look at america
and how we're falling apart during a
pandemic
or look at
great britain
they're sort of decaying culturally
um i mean
capitalism is definitely not the answer
like we're gonna
find the end of the road on this soon
so
either we're going to evolve or the
world's going to evolve without us
there's no personal property
community
commune i guess if you think communes
mean no personal property but
i think communes are like a
thing from the 60s or 70s i don't think
that really has any bearing on communism
or three years differing time period
i've been blessed with a visitor in the
same being jesus
wouldn't it be nice if jesus was real if
it was that simple
have you ever been to a communist
country if so what have you learned um
no not really i mean i've been to europe
which a lot of people would consider
communism
communist they're like no that's not
communism okay then let's do some of the
things that they do like health care and
working class rights and unions
and social safety nets no that's
communism
i thought you just said it wasn't
communism which one is it everything is
communism everything that will improve
your country is communism you just want
to keep it the way it is
um you are now john lennon i hope not
i don't want to get shot
right by central park
why do we cut i'm back to communism
it's a sticking point because we know
that
it's like
annoying to us because people keep
you know whatever people keep
gravitating towards it
i mean capitalism it's like if
capitalism is so great why does it
produce so many communists
like this is capitalism that we're
living in and yet half the country would
be considered communist by the people
who love capitalism so
uh it's like if it's so great why do so
many people
end up disgruntled and wanting to
improve it if it was great people would
be happy with it and there wouldn't be
disgruntled
citizens
i would love to visit cuba
cuba is a beautiful country and i love
how they stuck up to america and wasn't
just a sugar plantation for rich
americans and a resort they actually
were like we're gonna
we would rather be in charge of our own
destiny than to have america just do
whatever the [ __ ] they want within us i
think that's beautiful
um
i think that uh
i think it's good to stand up to police
and i think america has oftentimes
become the bully in the world
you think corporations and capitalism is
synonymous terms okey-dokey
i mean if you own capital why won't you
create an awesome corporation that takes
over everything
um
lack of ambition and laziness feel like
they deserve something for nothing
um i mean i think it's very easy to be
not lazy and to be ambitious i find it
very easy and i don't think that that is
the end goal of everybody is just to
work really hard at something stupid
i'm good at working hard and it's
choosing what to get work hard at that
is i think the more important skill and
i think a lot of people
are just fascinated with hard work
because we've been trained to and then
they work their ass off for someone who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about them wastes
their labor and does not create
something
um
good for the world
capitalism versus communism is a false
choice i agree with you i think that
we should just do what's best for the
country
and not judge policies based on what
superpower would have supported it in
the 50s
what is the best way to go forward as a
country if you're running this country
as a sim
city game a sim country would you not
give everyone health care and make them
work like animals
and resent your country because they're
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up or would you give
people health care because that seems to
work in countries there's ways to run
countries
and i think that we should implement
some of those ways
of running countries
uh i change the world more than any of
you ever have or will actually
a william buddy
wow
what a bold statement this guy has got a
lot of confidence in his uh past work or
something
uh uk nhs sucks you think that's like
just wait till you see american
healthcare
evolution has led us to this point we're
streaming and chatting thanks to free
market economy um i think that uh
free markets are good i don't think that
we have one right now or
and that we should work to having one
and
i think we should keep evolving instead
of just staying put
and conserving what we have now i think
evolution doesn't like it when you just
try to uh
not evolve so
yes i am i can't stop playing with it ue
boom charger way to pick that out
i think that in the future humans will
be able to converse with other animals i
think that'd be beautiful i think that'd
be awesome i don't think that we're
working on that right at all right now
we're like don't worry dolphins we got
this you guys just play around the
polluted waters we made for you but
would it be awesome if we could talk to
dolphins why don't we [ __ ] do that
like we should be doing that like that
should be like instead of having
everyone try to like tweak dating apps
uh or like sell advertisements
or insurance to
poor people we should uh or like selling
uh
i don't know
shamwow
we should have more people focused on
talking to dolphins
mass shootings are a result of media
sensationalism in my opinion
were you guys talking about that or is
that just something that you just
decided to volunteer i think that
media sensationalism is uh definitely a
part of it people are like oh i want to
be
i want to get that sort of treatment but
it's also a sign of very unhealthy
culture where people would want that
kind of attention
and i think that comes from our
our culture not being that healthy
free ross albrecht i agree with you the
dread pirate
scott pirate robert
pirate man
uh
value creation is important i think
okay
a lot of people are getting mad at me
because of my
communism where i want people to have
freedom and get paid fairly
instead of worshiping billionaires hans
agree there's no free market but
also thinks global commerce is
stratified by capitalism weird but okay
whatever
all right so this is so so fast okay uh
see you at the roamer room mike later
tonight and with that i need to go to
the secret show
and do some secret comedy i love you
guys i hope you guys
uh have a good night and that uh
a lot of you get your genitals licked
i think that would make the world a
better place
i hope that what do you think about of
working jokes out on streams i think
that i've done it and uh
hopefully that
if you uh
watch this much of my stuff uh
then maybe you won't mind if you hear
some of these ideas on a [ __ ]
stand-up comedy show
uh because i don't mind it when joe
rogan does that there's a blessing
that's during the produce more than i
want to mess up and suffering with
communism that's just a fact well i'd
say that uh capitalism has killed a lot
of people probably more than communism
and a lot of the people that died from
communism is because of uh
capitalist embargoes and [ __ ]
but yeah i don't want to talk about
communism
i want to wish you guys a good night and
uh
lick those genitals tonight
that's that's something that i want for
myself so
i want that for you i think that'd be
very nice for me so i
want to give that to you
but
i also don't want you to be as desperate
as i am so maybe don't focus on the
licking of genitals maybe focus on
fostering friendships
but uh yeah
um but yeah let's uh let's have a good
time and let's uh
let's fix the world and
give workers rights because most people
are workers
i don't want to end on communist
propaganda but uh i'm getting
getting triggered by all the capitalists
no um
oh yeah i'm just gonna end the stream
but uh yeah let's let's go lick some
genitals
genital licking